[Applause]
i saw this young man on monday night i
went to entombs when we got to town we
went to see the kill tony show
and uh this guy uh got his name picked
out of the bucket
he got up on stage and he [ __ ]
crushed
i know you guys are gonna love them give
it up for the very funny mr hands
kim
[Applause]
hey what's up gangsters gonna be here
chilling in the limelight
i used to date this yoga instructor who
was really into choke sex
and i was like do you enjoy breathing or
not
why don't you remind you millennial
so it's good to be here in texas uh i
love southerners because i'm from south
korea on the southern too only two
things i like
shooting commies in k-pop
that's all we do right get plastic
surgery
southerners that's what we do i love
being asian
uh asian women i think they're so much
better than asian men just because
they're sexier than us
but we look exactly the same
i look like you why are you bragging i
can throw on a wig and be a seven relax
[Music]
we all love white dudes one of the
easiest people to [ __ ]
are you bragging about that
it's great being asian i hate when
people make fun of us for eating dogs i
understand it's very shocking because in
america
doctors like family members but in asia
we treat our family members like they
have the numbers
there's
we should have one better in asia i'm
not sure baby girl
it's hard to date as an asian man
everyone these asian women are beautiful
not everyone thinks asian men are
beautiful which doesn't even make any
sense because i think asian women are
created
me [ __ ] i'm a crucial part of the
sexy process
please stop trying to skip me
if you have sex with me our children
will be very beautiful
what the [ __ ] is going on up here jesus
christ this isn't a [ __ ]
uh startup
there's mixer [ __ ] coffee show here
joe rogan was just up here you're
disrespecting the art form
so you guys can share your astrology
song to whatever [ __ ]
[Applause]
one celebrity comes here and you guys
lose your [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you just
like go to the bathroom joe rogan made
you all
shake your pants everyone went to the
bathroom at the same time
that was great i'm glad that they came
here
you guys are still talking about it what
are you guys into
minecrafter
anyways thanks for the opportunity
uh i love uh texas you know
i uh of america i'm not a racist i'm a
minority impossible how could i be
i don't even see race i only smell it's
a little polish in here
whenever i go to starbucks i tell them
that my name is ching chong bing bong
the third
because they doubt me i'm like excuse me
i come from a long line of bing bongs
[Music]
maybe it's her fault she needs to get
out more
she seems like a loser i think i can do
better
my friends are like dude you need to
learn how to talk to women
maybe or maybe women should learn how to
listen to hans
well i know what you want to hear about
minecraft
it's very interesting this one lady was
like did you know that my vagina is
technically a 3d printer because it can
make a baby
i was like actually your womb is a 3d
printer your vagina's the tray
it only prints one thing with lots of
awareness
it takes nine months to print
the whole time the sprinting is
complaining
he doesn't say i did not see any trains
that night
i love the ladies a lot of uh ladies
call me a premature ejaculator
premature to whom i came right at the
perfect time and it felt amazing
it takes maturity to not excuse yourself
i'm glad that women give birth i feel
like a man gave birth and be like bro
i'm gonna use so much protein and
creatine during my pregnancy
as big as like 27 pounds already bro
check out the six pack of the ultrasound
it's all about those schemes in the
first trimester
uh i love marvel movies i think black
panther is my favorite marvel movie
because they gave black children a hero
that they could live up to
but not just someone like miranda king
jr malcolm x or harriet
tubman or rosa parks junior marshall
george washington
jackie robinson willie mays will smith
obama oprah thank you to you mom
dangerous
now there's a big person that dressed
like a cat
congratulations
what are they gonna come out the yellow
panda what the [ __ ]
[Music]
i love being asian you know i i'm not a
racist but i did see a deep dude reading
a book in arabic on the airplane once
and i'm freaked out but then it's not
pulled the corner of the page and then
put the book away and i was like oh
thank god he's got future plans
um i don't understand all the sayings in
america and they say don't drop the soap
should be don't pick up the soap you can
drop as much
as you want it's bending over when
they're really catching
even if you don't drop the sun you're
still gonna get raped you're just gonna
really clean hands while it happens
like man i wanna get that kid but he
never wraps this up
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Applause]
your company's going nowhere i just got
a dance floor i might go somewhere
[Applause]
so even if the day goes well what
usually ends up happening is we go for a
drive until i can work with the courage
and color we were like 45 minutes ago
all right thank you very much good night